fire is ripping through California at
opposite ends of the state in the Sonoma
Valley wine region a hundred and thirty
kilometres north of San Francisco a
series of wildfires are out of control
some started on Wednesday night the
flashpoint is still not confirmed but
the state's largest power supplier
Pacific Gas and Electric say a
high-voltage cable malfunctioned minutes
before the fire started
intense wind gusts rapidly spread the
flames through bone dry brush to homes
and there's no let-up more strong winds
are forecast this weekend we're
potentially going to see a historical
wind event and it has it's highly
concerned that the vulnerable areas of
California could see some explosive fire
so that's why we are reiterating this
kind of vigilance that we're preaching
to everybody at least 2,000 people have
moved to safety but not everyone is
willing to leave well deputy sheriff
walked around the corner here yesterday
and told me it was mandatory that I
evacuate well he was wrong I don't have
to do anything but sit right here I want
to in Southern California a major fire
in Santa Clarita north of Los Angeles
has forced 50,000 people from their
homes within like ten minutes we started
to see the fire in the smoke getting
darker by our house
and we started packing everything
because we saw our neighbors doing it as
well and then that's when our brothers
started shouting out to me to get in the
car and we got the dogs in the car and
the fire was literally on our backyard
and it promises to be a tough weekend
for hundreds of firefighters the rough
terrain high winds and low humidity all
hampering their efforts to stop the
flames spreading Victoria Gaytan Bay
al-jazeera